What's great about knowing scientific notation an the property of exponents, is
that it can make these types of calculations a lot easier. We can actually
perform this without using a calculator. First I can change each of the numbers
into scientific notation and I need to make sure that I'm multiplying these
together, we still have multiplication between each of the numbers. This
numerator and this denominator are really just products of factors, so I can
regroup things. I'm going to regroup my powers of 10 next to one another, and
put the numbers next to one another. And here's where our exponent properties
come into play. I want you to simplify these powers of 10. What would be the
single exponent on the power of 10, if we simplified this part of the fraction?
Write your answer in this box.